[Musique]
oh
e
il était une fois dans un village une
jeune fille qui s'appelait mireille et
qui aimait beaucoup les oeufs à la coque
ce matin là elle était justement à table
avec un 9/20 sont copiés et s'apprêtait
à l'ouvrir avec une petite cuillère
au premier coup de cuillère la maison se
mit à trembler au second coup de
cuillère la maison sont mises à bouger
au troisième coupe toute la maison saute
en l'air et la tête d'un géant à paris
et je voudrais te bouger pose moi
d'abord atteint je te répondrais que ce
qu'elle veut dire par là je n'ai par une
réponse cependant le géant finissait de
sortir de terre est tirée sur d'immenses
chaussettes rouges lorsque surgit le
curé du village très fâché mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ça mais en voilà des
manières selon mireille sa maison tout
démoli mais ce n'est pas grave
le bâtiment sur ma partie
par la vertu de mes chaussettes bull que
la maison de mireille mois bon c'est
bien mais noël et vous en publie nutt
j'ai quelque chose à demander je
voudrait épouser murray mais c'est
impossible vous êtes trop grand vous ne
pouviez pas entrer dans l'église
mais comment faire pour un petit su mais
écoutez vous vous mais sympathique
les verts ne m'a pas le grand souk
siennois revenir dans un an et mireille
sera prêt pour mon épouse et attention
pas plus longtemps ou bab est il votre
bon sorcier chinois ou chine ce qui en
chinois signifie c'est bien vous le
grand sorcier
[Musique]
ce qui veut dire oui c'est moi et à
l'heure je voudrais rapetisse eu alors
le géant rentra dans une grande colère
et se met à crier très fort
cocteau ce qui veut dire est ce que tu
te moques de moi et maintenant
fais-moi rapetissé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou baby t-il votre sorcier bretons trois
mois plus tard le géant arriva en
bretagne il eût fallu un mois encore
pour trouver le sorcier bretons
excusez moi pourriez-vous me faire
rapetissé mais c'est très facile on peut
je suis trompé tony bibi
mais cela ne suffit pas je dois devenir
aussi petit qu'un homme et puis si j'ai
plus de pression
écoutez vous mais sympathique est elle
est donc de ma part vers le pape de rome
et où habitent ils ce denier donné à
rome
[Musique]
un mois plus tard le géant arriva à rome
mais il fallait encore quinze jours pour
trouver la maison du pas je veux devenir
aussi petit qu'un homme
ma fiancée m'attend dans quinze jours si
je suis trop grand jeu ne pourrait pas
entrer dans l'église pour l'épouser
comme cette hausse 1 je ne suis pas
sorcier mais vous m sympathique
j'ai vu fait clic et sousse pour allo
ici la femme vierge qui est à l'appareil
chez moi la pape diouf est ici 1 0 qui
voudrait devenir aussi pythie kent homes
ou su marier ce qui dit 'est-ce qu'il
n'a pas des chaussettes rouges votre g 1
et bien dites lui qu'il donne c'est
chaud ce cas la blanchisseuse et qu'ils
aillent se tremper les deux pieds dans
la merde en invoquant il verra bien ce
qui lui arrivera et quand je prévois
qu'il aura des ennuis dit l'icg ensuite
il pourra faire trois voeux qui seront
exaucés sur le champ mori mori morts
bonjour madame je viens chercher la
paire de chaussettes rouges de trois
mètres de long vous voulez dire les deux
sacs de couchage ce sont des chaussettes
moi quand je vois une chaussette dans
laquelle je peux entrer tout entière
j'appelle ça un sac de couchage et bien
donné l'émoi
oh
je ne suis plus j'ai un et sans mes
chaussettes rouges
je ne suis plus rien du tout
si seulement elle pouvait se réduire à
matin c'était son premier voeu qui se
réalisait mais comme il n'était plus
géant il ne pouvait revenir à pied au
village de mireille et je n'ai plus que
15 jours pour retrouver ma fiancée
si je pouvais être près d'elle je sais
tout ce que tu as fais pas moi
et aujourd'hui je t'aime dans six mois
nous nous marierons dans six mois
seulement mais il pensa soudain qu'il
lui restait un troisième feu à faire et
il dit à haute voix que ce soit le jour
meilleur depuis ce jour ils vivent
heureux et ils eurent atteint des
limites elle est beaucoup d'enfants